parasite is unlike any movie we've ever
seen and that's all thanks to you
director bong every shot is filmed
candidly and the story itself packs a
wild punch you put your heart and soul
into every one of your projects you even
became a temporary vegan while creating
the movie oh ja you enjoy working with
the same actors especially those you
form a bond with and it shows parasite
just wouldn't have been the same without
its cast of marvelous actors there is so
much about the cast of parasite that we
don't know from their struggles to their
achievements to their personal lives
keep watching to find out which south
korean star had to borrow fifty thousand
dollars from her fellow actors before
making it big in the industry before Cho
woo shik became the popular South Korean
actor he is today he spent a large
portion of his life in Canada his family
moved to British Columbia when moochick
was just 10 years old
the bilingual actor would eventually
attend Simon Fraser University however
wooosh ik felt as though there was
something bigger and better waiting for
him back in South Korea and he wasn't
wrong
so the humble actor who is known for
playing innocent and dorky characters
chose to drop out of the University and
move back to South Korea woo shik who
will turn 30 on March 26 2020 always had
a passion for acting and in 2011 he
would land a few small roles in South
Korean sitcoms during his time in Canada
woo shik chose to forgo his Korean name
and opted for the name Edward but his
close friends called him Eddie although
he now goes by the stage name Choi woo
shik his South Korean nickname is
loosing you girl
Choi young got her start in an r-rated
movie Choi you young played the role of
Park Yong kill in the movie parasites
the actors well known for her leading
roles and movies like the servant and
concubine and the TV series
I need romance but making headlines
wasn't always easy for yield young back
in 1997 when yo-jong was just 16 years
old she made her grand debut as a model
she was featured as a CC magazine cover
girl but by the time she was 18 years
old
healed young chose to try her hand in
acting but despite snagging small roles
in commercials music videos and TV shows
yeojeong wasn't making as much noise as
she wanted to she knew that something
drastic had to be done so when yo dong
was offered a leading role in their
erotic drama titled the servant she
didn't bat an eye when she read the
r-rated script many actors had refused
the role due to not wanting to film nude
scenes but Yeo Kyung knew that this
movie would help her step into the
limelight and she was absolutely right
although it's very hard to believe the
incredibly talented song kang-ho is a
self-taught actor kang-ho who plays Kim
Ki tok in the award-winning film
parasite always had a knack for making
people laugh but becoming a
professionally trained actor just wasn't
on his agenda instead of going to school
kang-ho shows to join the social theatre
group after graduating from high school
while he didn't fully understand the
many layers of acting just yet
Sango was a natural when it came to
instinctive acting and improvisation the
aspiring actor began to get noticed
after joining ki Caxias theater company
this led to him being approached by
producers who wanted to cast him in
their upcoming projects but kang ho
respectively declined every single one
of these offers because well he just
didn't feel ready that is until he was
given the opportunity to work as an
extra in the 1996 film the day a pig
fell into the well whence Kang ho felt
comfortable accepting bigger roles
despite his lack of schooling he quickly
became a household name
we have yet another fun fact about the
brilliant Choi woo shik coming your way
and it just might surprise you we'll
shake who portrayed Kim Koo and parasite
is no stranger when it comes to working
with the one and only director bong and
facts landing the role of Kim in the
2017 film oops Jia allowed lose shik to
gain international recognition but it
wouldn't be the first time that whoosh
ik made headlines all around the world
as this had happened just one year
before the release of okhta when whoosh
extort and train to Busan it's rare for
actors to become famous in all parts of
the world the boo shik is on his way to
accomplishing just that and now that
parasite has taken the world by storm
there's no way of knowing which movies
the bilingual actor will turn up in park
sodam has been a staple in the South
Korean film industry since her debut in
the 2013 film Zone yo but getting to
where she is today isn't an easy climb
so DOM is now internationally recognized
for portraying kim ki-jong in parasites
which is something she never would have
thought possible back when she was a
struggling artist the 28 year old actor
knew that she wanted to be a star ever
since she was in high school she fell in
love with acting while watching the
musical Grease but becoming an
accredited actor proved to be an uphill
battle despite her many talents it took
two and a half years of constant
auditions for her to land a breakthrough
role according to Glamour Fame so Dom
additions for dozens of roles every
single month only to get rejected every
single time but instead of admitting
defeat
she chose to pursue independent films
which helped her add credits to her name
and before long Saddam was welcomed into
the film industry with open arms
his action as previously mentioned song
kang-ho is a self-taught actor who
managed to become one of the biggest
stars in South Korea and it wouldn't be
long before King Ho took an interest in
voice acting in 2005 Kang ho voiced Alex
the lion in the Korean dub
of Madagascar unfortunately he was
replaced by a young wing young in the
sequel's kang-ho is a father of two and
like most parents he wants the very best
for his children in South Korea it's
important to make your parents proud
which is something children keep in mind
when pursuing careers but despite king
hos wishes his son
song Joong pyoung chose to become a
football player however Kang ho
eventually came around to the idea when
his son became a defender for the Suwon
Samsung Bluewings turns out Fame runs in
the song family while Kang ho is now an
acclaimed actor his parents might also
have had some reservations when they
found out that he wanted to become a
movie star how would you know it is a
well-known fact that South Korean men
are required to complete a compulsory
military service but Park Co June shows
to get his military duty over and done
with before pursuing his dream of
becoming an actor CEO Joon who plays min
in parasite began his service in 2008
and was discharged in 2010 and just two
years later CEO Jun managed to land his
first-ever role in the TV series shut up
family
the humble actor has never let Fame get
to his head no matter how many famous
friends he makes did you know that CEO
Joon is close friends with V from the
South Korean boy group BTS oh and he's
also super close with his parasite
co-star Jo whoosh ik no matter how
famous CEO Jun gets he remembers where
he came from and that once upon a time
he too struggled to land roles in movies
the outgoing actor has reached an
epitome of Fame and he's just getting
started
Lee Sun kyun is a hilarious actor who is
well known for his twisted sense of
humor he scored the role of Park dong
eek in parasite and has been growing in
popularity ever since the while Sun kyun
is making headlines in North America
he's already established as a beloved
actor in South Korea in fact Sun kyun is
so popular he's recognized by his fans
by a nickname alone he's been coined the
voice by his South Korean supporters and
no he didn't acquire this nickname as a
result of his love for musicals but
rather because he has a unique deep
voice that has helped him snag lead male
roles in dozens of movies huh however
son kun is no stranger to putting his
deep voice to the test that's right the
actor is a huge fan of musicals Sun kyun
has a love for theater
having been in musicals like grease and
love love love but did you know that
back in 2002 Sun kyun made his musical
debut when he was cast as a brad in the
Rocky Horror Picture Show
it isn't uncommon for directors to form
bonds with actors who eventually become
their go twos this is the case for song
kang-ho who has worked with director
bong joon-ho a handful of times on top
of working together in parasite kang ho
and Joon ho paired up to bring us the
hosts in 2006 and snowpiercer in 2013 it
was in snowpiercer that kang ho made his
debut in an english-speaking film and
just like parasite snowpiercer would go
on to bring the actor international fame
the following year in 2014 Kang ho would
also be cast in the controversial
American movie the interview however his
role would be on the small side kang ho
had a cameo in the movie playing a
soldier watching the interview director
bong and actor Kang ho have known each
other for years and continue to work
together amicably
but now let's find out which parasite
star had to borrow $50,000 from her
fellow actors just to make ends meet Lee
Jung hoon recently won the Best
Supporting Actress Award for her role in
parasite in which she portrayed moog
wing at first glance you might think
that Jang Yoon has been a famous actor
for many years now however Joong Geun
only rose to fame in 2013 she struggled
to become the actor she always wanted to
be until she was 40 years old but
keeping a roof over her head and working
part-time jobs proved to be most
difficult so much so that Jang hoon had
to borrow money from three of her fellow
actors to continue following her dreams
it took Joon Yoon 13 years to pay back
the 50 million won she borrowed but
everything worked out for the actor who
would go on to voice oppa in 2017
who is your favorite character from the
award-winning movie parasite tell us in
the comments 10 surprising facts about
the cast of parasite thanks for watching
like and subscribe for more we'll see
you next time on 2 things
[Music]
you
[Music]